june the 21st a day we'd all been
looking forward to
but putting coved restrictions behind us
by mid-summer
now looking much less likely coveted
cases are climbing
the pm's path out of lockdown now likely
to take
longer the figures are not looking good
are they
it's clear that the cases are going up
and that the levels of hospitalization
are going up clearly it's a matter of
serious serious concern
from where you were at the end of may
that's fair isn't it yes
that's certainly fair yeah and what we
want to do is make sure that the roadmap
is irreversible but you can't have an
irreversible road map unless you're
prepared to be to be cautious it's all
pretty depressing to be honest isn't it
i mean
can you do this at least can you really
assure our viewers
that your cautious but irreversible
route out of lockdown where we've got
to now we're not going back can you just
guarantee us that
i think that all our viewers
should be reassured by this that the
situation is
dramatically different from what it was
in either of the the first two waves of
the of the pandemic you're seeing a
different
group now going into uh hospital largely
and the outcomes on the whole
are are better that is caused by
the huge effectiveness of the vaccine
rollout so
so you you'll see what you're seeing
committed
you're committing that we are not going
back we won't be going back to taking
the kids
out of school we're not having any more
lockdowns it's done
the whole point of having an
irreversible
roadmap is just that to make it
irreversible
and to do that sometimes as i've said
repeatedly
you have to be cautious so you're
preparing to be mr delay not to be mr
reverse later down the line
just to cheer you up a little bit more
what i can tell you is that the
scientists are agreed about one thing
that they do not
think there is any case for going into
reverse
kovid not the only big problem facing
this prime minister
and the next biggest arguably one of his
own making
tensions building between the uk and eu
over post-brexit trading arrangements in
northern ireland
the two sides appear to be on a
collision course
a year ago you said there would be a
border in the irish sea and i'll quote
you
over my dead body and here we both are
there is a border in the irish sea
were you lying when you said there
wouldn't be one or did you not
understand the treaty that you signed
over brexit
i think that the treaty we signed i
signed
is perfectly reasonable i don't think
that the interpretation or
application of the protocol is is
sensible or pragmatic
there are all kinds of impediments being
constructed and we need to sort it out i
think we can sort it out by the end of
two i think we can sort it out but
it's up to our eu friends and partners
to understand that
you know we will do whatever it takes
and
you know there is some misunderstanding
what does that mean whatever it takes
but you won't honor the the protocol i
think if the protocol continues to be
applied in uh this way then we will
uh obviously not hesitate to invoke
article 16. so it wasn't an oven ready
deal and we could be having a trade war
in july
if i may say i think there's some i've
talked to some of our friends uh here
today who
who do seem to misunderstand that the uk
is a single
country in a single uh territory i think
they just need to get that into their
head
this problem in the irish sea something
this prime minister says he'll work out
but his fighting talk on brexit heard
loud and clear
by others here beth rigby sky news
cornwall